[Applause]
no one has dominated League of Legends
more completely than coma and faker the
to built a dynasty together creating an
unmatched legacy that spans the better
part of a decade but that's all changing
because comas dawn from SKT and now
faker is facing an uncertain future
[Music]
faker and comas relationship dates all
the way back to 2013
before faker ever stood on a
professional stage back when he was just
a superstar solo queue player and coma
recruited him right out of high school
to a budding SKT roster so - Tommen and
Tom monastery let's have done too much
testosterone Dan went to a matinee just
in Khartoum W&J faker joined SKT
secondary roster at Komets request
debuting in the spring season of the OGN
champions 8th domestic titles - msi
trophies one rift rivals win and I am
trophy and the coupe DeGraw three World
Championships faker and coma were simply
the best double six that get the flash
from a faker comes in it's easy to see
how great faker is I mean he'll just
look up one of his countless montages
but to understand how great comas
coaching is well you have to go to the
players I don't I think he's just
playing like not League of Legends he
playing just art his teaching arts how
to make the art in legal lessons not
teaching legal business that's what I
felt
managers join SKT the guys coaching
genius makes sense when you realize how
much effort he puts in day in and
the guy is always thinking about League
of Legends oh well as stressful and
watch me another voice chip Jimenez are
using oh yeah noggin get your stress I
put in the bank open up single calendar
Quran what amended to voice June 10 and
guided are using your dad's hope the
competitive circuit is harsh for people
like faker and coma they spend most of
the year competing between the lck
international tournaments and boot camps
but adversity breeds long lasting bonds
they've experienced the highest of highs
together as well as the lowest of lows
they've shared intense moments of
competition but aren't afraid to keep
things light the team is Fayette a 1
centimeter to ah he'll take it a table
you know would come you know for the
longest time coma single life was a bit
of a meme in the Korean community one
thing in and you don't know I think what
to do but eventually the impossible
happened
ah nobody expected comas named beyond
the list of people to leave SKT this
year now it's only faker who has to
carry s Katie's prestigious legacy with
yet another roster don't get me wrong
Teddy effort and coz aren't scrubs but
they weren't around in the heyday when
SKT just didn't lose ruin Amboyna
monotony in the bottom SK to achieve
ultra Douma SKT I'm gonna be a Yocto
Nikita who with the organization
rebranding the name and logo fakers the
only piece remaining of the SKT dynasty
the SKT dynasty as we know it is over
faker plus DOMA is no more but it
doesn't mean things are doom and gloom a
new dynasty can begin with coach kim
faker and teddy that's a really really
strong core 2020 is going to be a whole
new challenge for coma as well according
to an ESPN report comas heading to China
to coach the LPL team vici gaming we got
all these questions answered with
another ESPN report he did cash out in
China he ended up joining vici gaming
but the very interesting part in this
report if Goma turned down a multi-year
seven-figure deal from SKT for those who
haven't kept up with the LPL VG has a
long history of wasting legendary Korean
talents like dandy ma da easy moon and
baby
comas going to be put to the test as he
attempts to break the curse and fix the
dumpster fire that is CG gaming and with
coma Don we'll finally get to see faker
under a new and different coaching
system coach Kim is a legendary Korean
coach he's probably only 2nd Tacoma
Keith brought long Jiu and dumb when two
worlds and he one worth with Eiji coach
Kim will leave faker and the rest of SKT
in 2020 and while his trophy case isn't
as stuff like comas
coach Kim is a world champion the LPL
has never won before
change today the crownless are finally
king Invictus gaming for your 2018 world
champion we're about to witness a new
era and the SKT brand which means it's
up to faker in the rest of the roster to
fill this era with trophies and not
tears thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages